we're going to start that off with Nate
and Stephanie hi guys how are you great
good welcome to Nashville into our lobby
here at Ramsey solutions smells like
homemade cookies in there doesn't it
yeah it's delicious
yeah good to have you where do you guys
live Green Allen Nebraska whoa a bit of
a haul to Tennessee yeah to do a
debt-free scream so how much of you two
paid off forty thousand eight hundred
and sixteen all right very cool and how
long did that take 14 months well done
and your range of income during that
time 90 Ford and ninety nine thousand
very cool what do you guys do for a
living I'm a lab tech and I'm an
elementary school teacher oh good
very cool so what kind of debt was the
forty one thousand dollars what did you
people buy school cars home loan
personal loan paid off your house no
home improvement a home improvement loan
okay so you were kind of normal yes a
little bit of every kind of debt in the
world and so what happened fourteen
months ago we just got heard about the
program and decided to take the class at
our church Saint Paul's Lutheran Church
and took hold of it right away and dug
in deep straight into the class okay so
whose idea was it who raised their hand
to said I want to take that class that
would be Stephanie so when she said that
night what'd you say I went along and
honestly I wasn't really on board until
I heard you explain the budget being
telling your money where to go instead
of wondering where it went
and so naming those dollars and then I
was on board what the hell makes sense
then okay very cool all fine
well congratulations you guys so 14
months what did you do to get out of
debt
we just tightened down the budget that's
simple we were spending like crazy Dave
could we possibly send you to Congress
yes we would dr. house I think you would
do I think you would well no I mean not
by current standards but you would be
excellent senators yeah and congressmen
yeah you could tighten down the budget
just like that just just that simple it
is not that simple though because when
you do that it's
life isn't it it is what was the hardest
part what was the hard thing you cut
that hurt the most I think making
decisions for the kids you know cutting
down Christmas less activities yeah have
a look at those guys and saying no is
harder than looking at yourself and
saying no yeah yeah that makes sense but
the good news is you said no for a
little while now you can say yes there's
now you don't have any payments so how
long have you all been married 15 years
this summer all right very cool and so I
have you ever been bet 4e since you've
been married no never
and until 14 months ago in the boom just
like that you went after it because you
guys rolled up your sleeves I mean
that's a lot of debt making that income
did you sell something big nope we had
one loan forgiveness for my school loan
for 5,000 okay and that helped a little
but still the rest of it you just had to
get in attack mode
yep all right way to go so when someone
asks how do you get out of debt what's
your advice to them what are the key
things they need to do biggest key for
us one of them is using cash the
envelope system is big for us it helps
to save a lot of money okay sticking to
the budget having the budget and
sticking to it there's the key part yeah
writing it down it's not magical
sticking to it is the thing yeah very
cool well congratulations you guys Dave
we also want to give a shout out to our
church we're right in the middle of
momentum program right now oh yeah
Stephanie and I are the education
coordinators for that Oh Nate thank you
it's a huge push for us right now so
very exciting to be here and the name of
the church is st. Paul's Lutheran Church
in Grand Island st. Paul's Lutheran
Church and Grand Island Nebraska is
taking the whole congregation through a
goal of at least 80% of the congregation
and you guys are spearheading that and
boy you got a story to tell then don't
you now you got a video to go with it
yeah all right very cool well I'm proud
of you guys are very very well done now
what are your kids names and ages Isaiah
13 Elliot 10 Rachel's seven and Claire
four all right very cool and have they
been practicing all the way from
Nebraska they have their debt-free
scream do you think they're going to be
good or are they are they like an a a B
or a see do you think they
to be excellent they promise - okay all
right well they've been working at they
look like they're ready they looked like
they're ready well we're gonna give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's book signed by
him the retire inspired book because
that is the next step is to go ahead and
continue writing the chapters in your
book and your story and the next chapter
is to become very wealthy and extremely
outrageously generous change your whole
family tree that's the reason to get out
of that so well congratulations you guys
all right Nate and Stephanie Isaiah
Eliot Rachel and Claire from Grand
Island Nebraska forty-one thousand
dollars paid off in 14 months making 94
to 99 count it down let's hear a deck
three scream three two one it doesn't
get much better than that we appreciate
it very cool very cool
congratulations you guys congratulations
very proud of you
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy